among the classic and vintage cars the
VW bus has far more coal value than
design or horsepower appeal as a cold
car it leaves any Ferrari or Lamborghini
in the dust and nowadays the coveted
Samba models the first generation the
ones with skylights can fetch six-figure
sums the story began in 1946 with this
makeshift factory parts mover it
inspired the Dutch VW a Porter Ben pond
to make a sketch of a transporter based
on the beetle pan and the VW bus was
born but it had to wait till late 1949
to go into production around 12 years
later a one millionth first generation
VW bus rolled off the assembly line and
kept on rolling virtually unchanged till
1967
Johann Anita is a devotee of the first
generation called the t1 her version is
one of the legendary Sambas accelerating
through its four gears the 1.5 liter 44
horsepower engine can push the van up to
a maximum speed of 110 km/h in 1967 VW
shipped this bus to England now after
decades of daily use the white and blue
Samba is due for a thorough restoration
Johanna and her partner have brought the
bus to Germany
this is kamini drought she explains that
to her it's not just a car it's a whole
lifestyle when you drive away you don't
think about your job but about going
swimming or having ice cream that's why
it's a cold car this is in full equipped
out this 1962 Samba is another re import
from the United States in addition to
small roof windows the Samba has a cloth
sunroof in a sense it was a precursor of
today's people carriers but Samba was
never the models official designation
in the 1950s and 60s a steering wheel
gearshift lever speedometer and some
buttons was all the driver needed the
clock was a luxury
driving a VW bus is an object lesson in
taking life easy any compact can pass it
and then outrun it
Johanna admits that it can't be mistaken
for a sports car but that's not what
people look for in the bus it's for
puttering and bouncing around it's fun
to drive but very different from most
cars today Wisconsin lettuce not only in
Germany was the VW bus a hit in no time
it was puttering around the jungles of
India in the highlands of Tibet the VW
Transporter became a workhorse of the
world and the Americans fell in love
with it just as they did with the beetle
for decades the VW bus was a cheap
transporter for all trades and purposes
now collectors have discovered the first
generation and especially the Samba and
the first counterfeit Sambas have been
appearing on the market buyer beware and
be thorough
you're just kidding Johanna knows just
where to look the EM plate right behind
the front seat if the number there
starts with 24 it's an original Samba
bus if not it's a forgery
Samba buses also have double floor
panels if both panels are still there
it's very probably an original vendor
Spoonbill a motor to no stone is no
Malibu's unit the engineering is from
the beetle tried and tested and millions
of units the air-cooled four-cylinder
boxer engine keeps going and going even
with little or poor maintenance and most
parts are readily available
the days of the hundred-dollar hippie
vans carrying young rebels off to India
in search of the meaning of life have
faded into history in recent years
prices for the first generation tea ones
and above all the Sambas have soared a
positive result is that many old Sambas
are being lovingly restored a samba bus
an excellent original condition can run
as much as 100,000 euros even once
needing lots of work can bring in well
over 20,000 euros
Johanna sees a wave of retro hype with
all vintage cars right now so of course
since the VW bus has so much character
it gets carried right along on that wave
the Samba was something like the top of
the line there aren't many left the body
around the skylights was prone to rust
that also plays into the hype song Inga
roasted owned feather cups it is
impressive
today's samba owners can count
themselves among the lucky few
you